this is a tiny chunk of mouse cortex  the nanoscale structures and connections  are what process sensation from the  mouse's whiskers to make such a detailed  model researchers took specks of brain  tissue no bigger than a grain of salt  they cut the specks into thin slices now  the width of a human hair  is around 75,000 nanometers across the  slices for this study just 30 nanometers  using a technology called vast  researchers analyzed images of the  slices vast could identify and label  individual neurons glia blood vessels  and much smaller structures this  technique helps reveal the incredible  complexity of the brain but makes  understanding it even more daunting